en este video quiero que hablemos sobre
la valoración de un ácido débil y con
esta vamos a construir su curva de
valoración y con ella Vamos a encontrar
la concentración de mi ácido débil
gracias al punto de inflexión o de
equivalencia Así que para empezar
digamos que tenemos un balde con una
solución acuosa y esta solución acuosa
contiene algún ácido débil y como sabes
hemos hecho esto varias veces así que
imagínate que empiezo con h a es un
ácido débil que está en una solución
acuosa y este ácido va a estar en
equilibrio con su estado disociado y
ahora vamos a hacer una flecha para acá
Esto va a estar en equilibrio y ojo
Recuerda que am puede ser cualquier otro
tipo de grupo molecular de hecho es la
base conjugada del ácido débil Y
entonces qué nos va a dar Bueno si está
en equilibrio va a estar en equilibrio
con con algunos iones de hidrógeno
h+ este en una solución acuosa por lo
que producirá alguno de ellos pero
algunos de estos también van a estar
alrededor y a esto habrá que sumarle su
base conjugada es decir a menos en un
estado acuoso de lujo y al igual que lo
hicimos con una valoración del ácido
fuerte aquí tenemos a un ácido débil
vamos a medir su PH así que para esto
déjame tomarme una gráfica por aquí voy
a tomar aquí un pequeño rectángulo más o
menos como este y voy a hacer una
pequeña escala aquí justo como lo
hicimos en el video pasado así que el
punto más bajo voy a decir que es un pH
de 0 justo este por aquí por aquí a la
mitad voy a tener un pH de7 por aquí y
hasta arriba voy a tener un pH de 14 es
decir estamos subiendo el pH a medida de
que subimos en esta escala y ahora vamos
a pensar que empezamos con 1 l de esta
solución así que lo voy a poner Aquí
tengo 1 lro litro de esta solución No
sabemos la concentración de esta cosa
pero digamos que nuestra primera
medición del PH nos da un valor de tres
Así que Ah por aquí voy a tener al tres
y eso quiere decir que es ácida no Ultra
ácida pero es ácida y Bueno solo para
ser muy claros voy a poner que este es
el eje del PH Okay ahora date cuenta que
lo que vamos a hacer es valorar este
ácido débil y lo vamos a valorar de la
misma forma que se valora un ácido
fuerte y de hecho no importa si estás
valorando un ácido ya sea débil o fuerte
lo que vamos a hacer es valorarlo con
una base fuerte y en su dado caso de que
estés valorando una base ya sea débil o
fuerte el reactivo o lo que vamos a
Añadir va a ser un ácido fuerte así que
en en este caso vamos a pensar que vamos
a agregar o vamos a dejar caer algunas
gotas de una base fuerte para valorar
este ácido débil así que de igual manera
que en el video pasado Qué te parece si
nos tomamos un poco de hidróxido de
sodio vamos a tomarnos un poco de na ooh
y bueno para hacer las cosas más
interesantes vamos a hacer un poco de
cálculos vamos a decir que tenemos una
solución de 0.5 molar de
0.5 molar y esta vamos a agregarla de
poco en poco en incrementos de 100 ML es
decir una décima parte de 1 l pero lo
que realmente va a ser muy interesante
va a ser la forma de la curva de
valoración o La Curva del PH y Bueno
solamente para que lo tengas en mente
Qué pasa cuando nosotros tenemos naoh en
una solución acuosa vamos a escribir
esta reacción para el hidróxido de sodio
solo para recordarlo un poco si yo me
tomo
naoh y lo pongo en una solución acuosa
Entonces qué va a pasar Bueno pues este
se disocia por completo en el agua es
decir vamos a tener na positivo cationes
de sodio en una solución acuosa Okay más
Oh negativo es decir hidróxido también
en una solución acuosa y lo importante
es que este se disocia por completo en
el agua Así que cuando le echas Incluso
un poco digamos no sé que vertimos 100
ML de una solución a 0.5 molar y también
déjame escribir eso vamos a vertir 100
100 ML que bueno Esto es exactamente lo
mismo que una décima parte de 1 lro
estás de acuerdo ahora este 0.5 molar es
su molaridad Así que esto nos dice lo
siguiente voy a tener medio mol de este
de aquí y por lo tanto este se disocia
por completo lo que quiere decir que voy
a tener medio mol de este y de este
también dicho otra manera voy a tener
medio mol de iones de hidróxido por cada
litro por lo tanto si hablamos de que
tenemos 0.5 molar pero solamente tenemos
un décimo de litro voy a tener Qué bueno
pues esto me está diciendo que realmente
lo que voy a tener es la mitad de un
décimo o dicho de otra manera 1 sobre 20
o lo podemos ver como
0. 05 moles
moles ahora digamos que este punto de
aquí y déjame Hacerlo con un color un
poco más fuerte este de aquí nos va a
decir cuál es el pH de la solución
cuando agregamos los primeros 100 ML 100
ML de modo que solamente vamos a tener
0.05 moles de iones de hidróxido y lo
voy a ir tirando en nuestra solución Y
qué va a pasar Bueno pues estos van a
empezar a absorber a alguno de estos
protones de hidrógeno por lo tanto Eso
quiere decir que va a aumentar el pH Así
que si nos fijamos aquí lo que va a
pasar es que va a aumentar el pH y el pH
se va a mantener subiendo pero este de
aquí es una solución amortiguadora lo
cual es clave para recordar esta Va a
ser una solución amortiguadora y eso
quiere decir que va a absorber alguna de
estas cosas pero esta solución
amortiguadora está en equilibrio es
parte de este ácido débil por lo que
tiene una reserva aquí de su forma ácida
Así que cuando empiezas a bajar estos
estos empiezan a bajar mediante la
adición de esta base fuerte Recuerda que
estos están absorbiendo a estos Entonces
qué va a pasar esta reacción se va a
mover En esta dirección para tratar de
compensarlo se va a tratar de mover
hacia esta dirección la idea va a ser
tratar de llenar o de reemplazar justo
lo que tenemos aquí pero como está en
equilibrio no va a lograr conseguir que
regresemos a donde estábamos antes pero
va a amortiguar el estrés de este
equilibrio Así que lo que va a suceder
Es que la concentración de este ácido
también va a bajar esto también va a
bajar porque va a tratar de rellenar
justo esta cosa que tenemos aquí y cada
vez que la reacción vaya en esta
dirección este de aquí va subir estás de
acuerdo este va a subir porque recuerda
realmente nadie está absorbiendo a esta
base conjugada que tenemos justo aquí
solo estamos absorbiendo a los iones de
hidrógeno y conforme absorb vamos más y
más y más de estos iones de hidrógeno
esta reacción irá cada vez más hacia la
derecha Pero conforme va más y más y más
hacia la derecha entonces solo estamos
agregando más y más y más de estos
porque recuerda cuando esta base
Realmente está tomando a este ácido que
tenemos aquí lo único que está tomando
es pues la mitad de esto dicho otra
manera lo único que está tomando es a
los iones de hidrógeno y por lo tanto la
parte de la H esto se convierte o es
absorbido por la base fuerte mientras
que esta base conjugada esta de aquí va
a quedar sola y esto nos lleva a pensar
que en algún momento cuando hemos
añadido la cantidad exacta de Oh de
hidróxido la cantidad exacta como para
cubrir todos estos protones de hidrógeno
y nos quedamos sin protones de hidrógeno
entonces La pregunta sería qué va a
pasar Bueno pues justo cuando llegas más
allá de este punto al Añadir aún más de
estos que tenemos aquí esto se va a
poner bastante básico se va a disparar
arriba el pH porque estás añadiendo más
y más y más de estos Oh de estos
hidróxidos que no están siendo
cancelados con estos protones de
hidrógeno y eso porque ya no hay y
entonces no hay nada que pueda reponer a
estos protones de hidrógeno y vas a
tener una reacción bastante básica Pero
antes de eso qué va a pasar cuando
llegamos al punto en el que todos los
hidróxidos de sodio estos de aquí los
tomamos los agregamos y esto neutraliza
completamente a estos de aquí es decir
neutraliza completamente a estos de aquí
si te das cuenta Solamente vamos a
quedar dar con estos de aquí son los
únicos que nos van a quedar Y
seguramente podrás decir Oh tenemos un
pH de 7 porque todo el ácido se
neutraliza pero no no tenemos un pH de7
como lo hicimos en los ácidos fuertes
porque aquí conforme absorbimos esta
cosa nos mantuvimos agregando una base
conjugada Recuerda que es una base real
aún tiene propiedades básicas Y qué va a
pasar entonces cuando agregamos el
suficiente hidróxido de de sodio de modo
que esto va a neutralizar a este de aquí
si por ejemplo esto fuera un ácido
fuerte y no sé se me ocurre pensar en el
cloruro de hidrógeno entonces aquí
tendremos un buen de cloro ve aniones de
cloro pero el cloro a pesar de que es
una base conjugada no tiene propiedades
básicas por lo tanto no va a aumentar el
pH de la solución pero este de aquí esta
cosa de aquí incrementa el pH de la la
solución déjame ponerlo incrementa el pH
el pH y de hecho hemos visto esto en
videos pasados así que una vez que todo
esto absorbió a todo esto es decir en el
punto de equivalencia o en el punto en
el que el número de moles de Esto va a
ser Exactamente igual al número de moles
de esto vamos a tener un pH alto Así que
va a estar por este lado imagínate que
es justo este punto punto y vamos a
tener un pH más grande que siete no sé
supongamos en este punto y después si
nosotros añadimos más y más y más de
este reactivo de esta base entonces
nuestro pH seguirá aumentando se va a
ver más o menos así aproximándose al 14
o incluso yendo encima de él pero lo más
importante aquí y lo que quiero que veas
es cómo se ve esta curva de valoración
esta curva de valoración o del PH se va
a ver parecida a Esto va a empezar
creciendo hasta que llegue un punto en
el que va a tener que cambiar y después
va a pasar algo justo así así se vería
la Gráfica de esta curva de valoración Y
es más déjame quitar esto para que no te
confundas y si una vez más nos fijamos
en el punto más empinado nos vamos a
encontrar a este punto de aquí que justo
ahí justo ahí es el punto de
equivalencia es el punto en el que
tenemos la misma cantidad de hidróxido
que ha absorbido todo este hidrógeno Así
que este va a ser nuestro punto de
equivalencia y si vemos a este punto de
equivalencia puedes decir okay Si este
es mi punto de equivalencia cuando Le
agregué no sé supongamos se me ocurre 2
l 2 l que por cierto están a 0.5 molar
es decir añadimos 2 l de mil reactivo
Entonces cuántos moles agregaste Bueno
si son 2 l a 0.5 molar Eso quiere decir
que en este punto en este punto hemos
agregado 2 por 0.5 un mol 1 mol de iones
de hidróxido y cuando agregas un mol de
esto Qué significa bueno significa que
has agregado un mol de la sustancia que
va a absorber todos estos de aquí todos
los protones de hidrógeno que tengas
tanto en el ácido como en mi solución
acuosa Así que claramente podrías decir
lo siguiente que este mol de Oh es
Exactamente igual a decir que la
concentración de ha más la concentración
de protones de hidrógeno todos los que
había que no estaban en el ácido es
decir mi hidrógeno inicial Esto va a ser
igual a 1 molar ahora en la mayoría de
las clases de química te vas a topar con
que este número de aquí es mucho mayor
que este número de aquí Y eso es para la
mayoría de los ácidos débiles puedes
darte cuenta de eso porque si nos
fijamos en algunos de los pka para
algunos ácidos débiles este número sería
mucho mucho menor y en fin no Quiero
meterme en todas las cuentas pero en
esencia lo que quiero decirte Es que
esto es un indicador de la concentración
inicial de tu ácido débil Así que para
encontrarlo lo único que necesitas es
mantener la valoración hasta llegar al
punto de inflexión y dirás justo este
punto de aquí ocurrió cuando agregué 2 l
del reactivo que correspondió a 1 mol de
Oh Eso quiere decir que voy a tener un
mol de mi ácido original en la ecuación
voy a tener un mol de mi ácido con el
que empecé justo aquí y bueno una cosa
también bastante interesante es que si
tenemos un mol de este de aquí es decir
justo lo que buscábamos un mol de mi
ácido original en la ecuación Y
empezamos todo con 1 l antes de que
empezáramos la valoración Eso quiere
decir que esencialmente teníamos un mol
de este ácido por este litro o dicho de
otra manera que teníamos una molaridad
de uno y ya
acabamos